on vient de parler d'enfouissement des
déchets avant d'en arriver là il ya tout
un cycle de vie mais qu'elles vous vous
intéressez oui et lors d'un échange
conclus par courriel vous m'avez parlé
des arbres de noël
je pense qu'on est pas mal au bon moment
pour pour en discuter
donc la question arbres naturels ou
arbre artificiel
je sais que plusieurs d'entre vous
connaissez la proche cycle de vie
l'analyse de cycle de vie qui est un
super outil pour justement éviter de
déplacer des impacts d'un endroit à
l'autre c'est que par exemple si je
donne un exemple concret on peut on
entend beaucoup les véhicules
électriques que c'est important bon
d'investir dans l'est parce que c'est à
l'utilisation salam sall à moins d'un
paquet tout et c'est vraiment quelque
part mais si on fait pas attention à
tout le processus cycle de vie
c'est-à-dire de l'extraction des
matières des matières premières jusqu'à
la fin de vie on risque de juste prendre
des choix de société
privilégier des solutions quand on se
dit aussi c'est la solution à qu'il faut
faire et de déplacer si je reviens pour
les véhicules électriques
oui à l'utilisation c'est moins
polluants mais il reste que la
technologie au niveau des piles
électriques elle est pas encore l ai pas
encore optimale est pire que ça c'est
qu'on utilise beaucoup les piles au
lithium et au cobalt et ça c'est une
ressource qui va être disparu dans moins
de 40 ans donc oui on peut privilégier
sa met en risque de déplacer si on prend
pas en compte tout le cycle de vie du
produit
au-delà de ça aussi au québec c'est
correct de faire la promotion des
véhicules électriques parce qu'on a le
drôle électricité mais si on regarde par
exemple dans d'autres provinces ou si le
charbon et que l'on fait la promotion de
seul le charbon ccc le plus polluant de
tous les les énergies fossiles
on va faire du déplacement l'impact puis
donc la solution c'est le fameux arbre
de noël
est ce qu'on prend eau ou en pro b mais
je vais vous dire ça dépend si ça c'est
la position inconfortable de dire ça
dépend mais moi je veux savoir
je pourrais vous dire il ya eu une
analyse de cycle de vie qui s'est fait
sur les sapins de noël
donc grosso modo si vous acheter un
sapin artificiel et que vous regardez
pendant vingt ans vous allez être plus
écologique que d'apprendre ça
naturellement 20 ans donc vous devez
vous poser la question à types de
consommateurs ce que vous allez garder
votre sapin air pendant 20 ans mais donc
c'est toujours des choix des compromis
c'est cette position l'aude
on cherche c'est quoi la meilleure
solution mais on n'a pas de solution
plus verte
c'est juste des solutions - brume et qui
vont avoir certains compromis associés
c'est un petit peu 5 confortable